[Music]
I'm the one
all right so we got a home team podcast
today with a friend in the house Rob
Smith uh we got a lot to talk about if
you don't know who rob Smith is you will
in a minute he's a decorated Iraq war
veteran he served five years in the Army
including two tours in the Middle East
during operation Iraq Freedom he was
awarded the Army accommodation medal and
combat infantry badge he has spoken
about politics and current events at
Yale University Google Deutsche Bank
Vanderbilt University and dozens of
other colleges universities and
companies Across America there's a uh I
want to say a special you did that got
10 plus million views was it advice yeah
it was the uh advice conservatives
debate black liberals phenomenal I mean
if you've never seen it you got to watch
it and then you're based out of uh
Florida now you're with Turning Point
USA contributor you promote their values
of fiscal responsibility for free market
limited government daily annual holiday
master's degree from Columbia Columbia
University yes I was with Turning Point
okay I was with Turning Point did a lot
of work with Turning Point great
organization
um Now sort of kind of doing my own
thing I love it uh but yeah so the uh
that Vice video was crazy went crazy
black conservators versus black liberals
uh still like I've done a lot of stuff
but that's still the thing that people
come up to me airports Amtrak whatever
like oh and that thing still flies crazy
to this day somebody goes and watches
that like it still goes hard I love it I
think honestly I think everybody who
hasn't seen it should see it because the
exchange how you handled it how you know
they got triggered and uncomfortable oh
my God I'm he's kind of doing the same
thing to him it's a very uh interesting
exchange to watch but it's good to have
you on uh we've got a lot of topics to
cover today a ton of topics obviously
this guy named uh what's his name Ron I
want to say right Ron DeSantis is
announcing that he's running for office
today he's got a big announcement we
don't know what it is but of course we
all know what it is making the
announcement with Elon Musk on Twitter
spaces and uh everybody cells from
mainstream media is probably
disappointed that that announcement
wasn't being made on mainstream media
Lots changing in the marketplace so
we'll talk about that we know economy
wise Tom you got a few things to talk
about with Jamie Diamond warning uh some
additional banks that may go out of
business uh due to the commercial real
estate loans yeah inflamish inflam
inflation uh pummeled U.S household
finances last year indeed we got a few
things to talk about with apple
announces multi-billion dollar deal with
broadcom for us-made ships China Taiwan
tension daily wire just announced that
they're planning on taking their podcast
potentially on Twitter following
Tucker's lead so they may also take
their podcast to Twitter reports of
Instagram making Twitter competitor
prompts comment from Linda who's now the
CEO of Twitter looming existential
crisis for cable news wait till you see
the data that we have here Tucker
Carlson sends a legal threat to pack
urging him to run for president and
that's a Newsweek story and we got a few
other things that's going on back here
with Target is flip-flopping with the
decision that they made and then MSNBC
guest claims Florida is about to be a
terrorist state for black and lgbtq
community and then Berkeley holds a
segregated graduation ceremony for black
students only and last but not least
this is a story that we want to touch
Tom doesn't want to touch it but we're
probably going to touch it it's how Bud
Light blew it and before we get into the
stories guys we're about to announce our
next step live we're about to announce
our next live podcast for those of you
that have attended it you know how
insane it gets whether it's uh now that
we're doing it at night the Cigar Lounge
afterwards the exchanges the
conversations the networking if you want
to be one the first to know because the
moment we announce it the VIP Tech
itself within the first seven eight
minutes the last two times they saw
within the first seven eight minutes so
if you want to know and be the first
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again text the word
podcast three one zero three four zero
one one three two having said that let's
get right into the story with DeSantis
and musk I think we start with that
right off the bat so the center set to
announce 2024 run for Twitter with Elon
Musk this is a New York Times story
that I'm reading uh Governor Ron
DeSantis said to announce presidential
campaign on Twitter in a live audio
conversation with musk sources reveal
that the census aims to reach a wide
online audience stating it's the right
thing for society and it's the great
thing for our brand that's what musk
said the sentence faces the challenge of
capturing attention amid competition
from former president Donald Trump who
is expected to return to Twitter uh uh
by the way vitsync is expected to return
to Twitter that's pretty well they
pro-trump Super PAC criticizes
desantis's campaign launch as out of
touch and mocks his after party at the
upscale Four Seasons Resort in Miami
Moscow will moderate the Twitter event
has expressed support for the scientists
in the past although not formally
endorsing and musk has shifted his
support toward the right and has engaged
the right-wing conspiracy theories on
social media again remember this is a
New York Times story Rob thoughts on the
story all right so first of all
um people have to understand about
Rhonda Sanchez is that he loads the
mainstream media he really he really
does does not like these people okay
these people
um attack him they try to obfuscate they
try to do all these different things he
does not like these people so this is a
brilliant move to take his announcement
to Twitter to Elon Musk because he knows
that that is going to be the most
powerful platform these platforms that
we have online whether it's YouTube
Facebook or but Twitter is the most
powerful Free Speech platform in the
world right now so that is where he's
going to take his message he knows that
as he runs for president over the next
year to year and a half the mainstream
media which basically focuses as like an
arm of the Democrat Party at this point
is going to attack him
um at every turn uh it's a brilliant
move I think that'll be very interesting
and you know as far as you know
desantis's uh capabilities as prisoners
possibilities I have a lot of thoughts
that I'll get into if you want me to
um so I dinner with the Santas at the
governor's mansion a couple months ago
and I think I told you about this the
last time that we came here right
um so he was literally sitting right
here there's a three and a half hour
dinner and and it was endless it was a
long dinner but I really got the sense
of who it was endless
um but I I got the sense of who DeSantis
really is right outside of uh you know
how the the team presents him on Twitter
and all this other stuff and so this is
the thing this person is whip smart this
is a very very very smart man this is a
very smart individual policy wise okay I
think the issue that he is going to have
is in these interactions with regular
people that the the sort of small talk
the things that you have to do is
somebody that's an entrepreneur somebody
that is a politician or somebody that is
a public figure these are not things
that come natural to him okay and it
becomes a very obvious uh when you spend
more than five minutes with him so I
think that the fear is if he gets into
this situation where if you ever went to
the Iowa State Fair you know this is
basically a humiliation ritual that we
put our candidates for office or our
candidates for president through as a
society and you've got a Rhonda Santos
out in the Iowa State Fair like you know
eating the hot dog on a stick or
something like that and having to engage
with with people the opportunity there
and the threat there is to have a very
negative viral moment where he's kind of
just being a little awkward the left
takes that blows it up
got it Tom what are your thoughts on
this well I agree with that and I also
think that what uh that there's a macro
element and you're in the system so you
see some of this yes the ad sales vice
president said MSNBC CNN and Fox News
are pissing on themselves today because
social media and alternative platforms
are taking the biggest show of the year
to the American people scary part right
when you think of being a guy that's
from that space yeah you know to see I
bet they're probably losing their minds
how the hell do we lose this yeah and I
think that this is part of the strategy
you have to understand the desanta
strategy and his entire team is that
they want to make the mainstream media
irrelevant okay they do because they
know that these people are going to be
anti no matter what box though because
Fox to me is more descent than they are
Trump right now you know I do not know I
think that he's still going to use Fox
Fox is still you know a very large cable
news sort of divinity right he went
there um to promote his book he he still
uses that and he knows that he will get
a friendlier interview with Fox than he
will get from a CNN or an MSNBC but I
think the long-term strategy is in his
eyes
um to delegitimize mainstream media
um in the eyes of the people that are
his actual base I asked him at that
dinner uh he was actually he actually
got a little pissed at even the
suggestion of this question I was like
oh you know when you go on book tour
you're gonna go to the Views like why
would I go to the view you know they're
not going to give me a fair shape blah
blah blah and he kind of like went on
and on I was like okay so it's you know
not going to the view you know so I'm
funny I just wrote down here do you
think he's gonna end up doing the CNN
Town Hall dmsnbc going on The View going
on opposition going on all those guys I
think the strategy uh uh I I think if
musk is in his ear musk knows they're
going to get him more eyeballs on
Twitter spaces and people will be able
to answer questions ask questions from
him while they're going back and forth I
think that part's going to be the new
Direction because when you are making an
announce like you know even a Siena Town
Hall the CNN Town Hall who's asking
questions the people that are in there
right but it's still formatted in a
weird you know mechanical way right but
if you do Twitter spaces it's set up in
a way where it's like hey so tell us
what you think about this Hey Hey Ron I
had a question for you that one time
what happened with Disney and Bob Iger
would you have done that again hey the
decision you made to go to six weeks
abortion do you think that kind of hurts
you and you could have kind of set that
aside and not really gone there why did
you go there in the first place would
you say that was one of your mistakes
Twitter spaces you can't really moderate
what people can ask most people on Town
Hall they stand up and they do the
following think about it they go like
this hi Governor Ron DeSantis I just
want to tell you I love the work you do
I'm a resident of Tallahassee you're
amazing okay so if you were to dude
Nobody Does this on Twitter yeah it's
completely scripted this is the
mechanical part to go away from it but
there's there you got some thoughts you
want to say yeah of course okay go for
it I got a few other by the way at this
dinner was his wife there oh yeah yeah I
did get to talk about Casey okay so
everything that Rhonda santis lacks in
terms of you know maybe a little
personal Charisma in terms of being able
to interact with people Casey has it
times 20. agree Casey DeSantis is
absolutely fabulous she has all of that
stuff so she is going to be such a huge
part of this campaign and and I think
that she will be a very big part of this
moving forward she's gorgeous she's
intelligent this was a um a television
news woman before but before you know
she she became his wife and became the
first lady of Florida right so
everything that he's lacking in that
department she has and I think I think
she's going to be a huge star I think
that conservatives are going to fall in
love with this woman if they have not
already yeah I think like I think not
speak highly enough I think mothers are
going to fall in love with her I think
just Independents are going to follow I
think Democrats are going to fall over
we also have the opportunity to meet
with DeSantis recently without uh just
disclosing much details and Ron and
Casey sat at the head of a room and
there was a handful of us in this room
and I fully agree with you Ron DeSantis
is 100 a policy wonk even when he walked
in the room it wasn't like hey everybody
thanks for being here you know hey how
you doing buddy yeah yeah you know none
of that it was like hi so my agenda
worked out and basically in the fiscal
year and then we're like oh okay we're
getting right into this yeah yeah and he
just went
teachers unions and this and that no
um
Humanity like marketing perspective
whatsoever but she spoke and it was very
impressive Pat would you agree yeah I
mean there's no question about it that
that she is a uh formidable first lady
yeah and and by the way if you go back
to the last eight first ladies I
actually go back to the first let's go
all the way back to Reagan okay Nancy
was super protective if you read books
about Nancy she was a ball buster behind
closed doors and she would not let you
take advantage of her husband very cool
yeah very cold so sometimes she hurt
uh uh you know the direction she would
you know he would go but eventually she
she was somebody you had to win over she
wasn't John F Kennedy's wife Jackie
Jackie was just beautiful and she wasn't
like you know she was just put together
nice clothes marketing all that stuff
but Nancy was actually like a fighter
and people feared her you go to any of
the other ones you know we've had great
ones you know there's a Michelle Melania
but to me Michelle is a Michelle is a
superstar of a first lady uh for the
Democratic party she's not good for the
Republican side you know she would dig
at uh Obama all the time and you know
she's this he's that that is a very good
play for the Dems maybe not on the
Republican side Casey is a first lady
for a you know the Republican audience
independent also winning part of the
left as well and if you look at Trump's
wife Trump's wife is a model who has an
audience but Trump's wife's not going to
get in there and do do the work that you
know not do the work but she's not gonna
get in there and saying hey I'm going to
campaign over here you go over here I'm
gonna go give this speech that was his
daughter Trump's wife the role of a
first lady in a strange way was played
by Ivanka correct which she was a
Powerhouse when she spoke people lost
their minds when she was because she had
that
that part with her but there's a few
things that that we have to be thinking
about right now with this announcement
okay so one is it too late okay so let's
let's address some of the FAQs is it too
late uh you know it's already too late
he's panicking he's kind of announcing
right now I thought he was going to make
the announcement after I'll do this
stuff why is he doing it sooner okay
maybe he's doing that after the Disney
stuff that happened maybe he's doing it
after some of the you know the not the
best start to a campaign what people
have to realize is Trump announces uh is
uh in 2015 he announced running on June
2014 I believe or something can you
check Trump's birthday whatever Trump's
birthday was that's when he announced
and he wasn't a political figure so for
him to say I'm gonna run June 14 June
14th yeah he announced 2015 June 14th so
essentially that's what that's three
weeks from today so if he announced this
today he's still fine two uh uh Trump is
still ahead 37 as of today so it's not
like it's a small lead that they have
three most of Trump's ads have been
towards the scientists a lot of the ads
they've been spending and I think I saw
on Fox the article that Trump spent more
money uh ads against the scientists than
they did for midterms more money was
spent on ads against the centers than
midterms what does that mean that means
the mega even Trump's campaign sees him
as a formal formidable threat right
there Trump's pack spent 15.3 million
dollars on the center set more than
midterms total so we have to know that
as well now Tim Scott comes out with 20
million dollars he announces it this
week right 20 million bucks which is
fine you got 20 million bucks and I
think Tim's going to get the job on
whoever the next Administration is and
he may be a great VP candidate I think
he is a role player the saint is they
said 86 million what four weeks ago he's
going to get 100 million I wouldn't be
surprised if Elon gives him 50 100 200
million dollars this is because here's
what I think is happening this is this
is what I think is happening with this
whole Elon thing I think this is more
about elanden is about the santis yeah
this kind of sounds weird but I think
it's about more Elon than the santis I
think Elan
uh is realizing
uh this political game is kind of cool
and you can be uh Iron Man which is cool
and he played a role of Iron Man what
happens when you're Iron Man well you
know you hook up with all the top
Hollywood celebrity you know uh women
and you can kind of go and say yeah I
used to date her yeah I used to be yeah
Amber Heard yeah yeah so you're kind of
over that now what okay next thing is
well I don't know I get respect but
Legacy it's just a pretty interesting
fight I don't like what they're doing
kind of like what Sebastian was saying
yesterday but now it's kind of like you
know what job is open what job is open
who the hell is the next Murdoch who the
hell is the next media who didn't I
wouldn't mind competing for that kind of
power and what if I have the business
what if I have the billions I can never
run for office like that Turner I can
never run for office like uh uh you know
Trump what if I do this so musk is a
case study to show can a Musk
with the help of Rogan and others
convert and catch up on a 37 point lead
that the opponent has if they catch up
you know what this says in the
marketplace in the marketplace the most
powerful men in politics is officially
Elon Musk if he pulls this off if he
doesn't pull it off and Trump still wins
and by the way even if they get close
and the difference is like three four
five percent Elon Musk will be the most
you know how that's Suzanne Scott is the
number one person yeah next year's
mediaites list needs to scrap everybody
else and put Elon Musk as number one do
you think this is going to be considered
an endorsement
for Ron descent like this is a big deal
like you talked about that he's
basically making the the Legacy Media
irrelevant I think he still is going to
need to
you know make appearances on mainstream
media CNN Fox I don't think he's
necessarily gonna make them irrelevant
he doesn't want to be fully reliant on
that yeah for sure but this move with
Elon this is this is massive so first
Tucker yeah now you got DeSantis this
upcoming announcement the question is
Trump's been so aligned with true social
he hasn't made any concessions to doing
anything with Twitter is this going to
be the straw that broke the camel's back
to make Trump say all right screw it if
DeSantis is getting all this attention
with Elon freaking musk on Twitter I
gotta go ahead and head to Twitter I
want to know if that's something that
you think Trump's going to do I believe
so absolutely I believe Trump will be
back on Twitter
um and honestly you know the true social
thing hasn't really taken off the wave
that they wanted to remember yeah you
think uh so remember when he they
announced the digital world acquisition
corporate the D walk thing right and so
basically what that was and I'm gonna
get in trouble with MOG world but that's
fine like I'm out of trump world I did
that I don't care anymore look a lot of
them who knew what was happening made a
lot of money off of the D walk thing
right and then it went right there so
all them made their money and then they
disappeared right and so true socialist
was going to be a big part of that I
remember all the rumors about you know
when Trump uh you know left the White
House that they were gonna announce
Trump TV team they were going to do this
whole media conglomerate thing right so
yes Trump will absolutely be back on
Twitter here's the thing that people
don't understand about Trump
because number one nobody in the circle
wants to say anything negative okay and
in one of their fundamental weaknesses
right now is that they live in a bubble
where nobody can speak the truth Trump's
fatal flaw is that he just loves
attention too much he loves attention so
much
um that he will not just stay on true
social uh the true social post can make
a little bit of a news cycle and make a
couple blogs whatever but him being on
Twitter is seismic and that is a man and
that is a movement at this point that
just thrives on attention
um and I would not be surprised if he
came back to Twitter literally within
the space of the next few weeks just to
sort of Tamp down on some of this
momentum um in this conversation that
we're having about Elon and about
um DeSantis announcing on Twitter so
yeah he'll be back there absolutely 100
you know I think there's an angle here
and and maybe because I'm I'm a little
geeky that I see
um I had the privilege of being at some
confabs where I saw some tech CEOs at
certain points in their career and then
I I see them later how they engage the
media and talk to the media I saw
Zuckerberg on stage 2008 2009 that guy
was not ready for prime time now he can
carry his own on a congressional hearing
and with the media and if you want to
take a look at 15 years ago the way
um Elon Musk and Peter Theo and the rest
of the and Reid Hoffman and the rest of
the PayPal Mafia you look them doing a
team interview on TV and disrupting
Financial Services PayPal they were
Geeks they were college guys they were
they were barely able to carry the
conversation now look at Elon Musk how
he can play the media and how he can
present it if this week is about Elon
Musk having a big week for Twitter the
platform having a big week for Elon Musk
the power broker and then having a big
week in general for attention if that's
all it is then that's all it is but if
there is a true friendship and a
relationship forming between DeSantis
and musk and Musk and say Ron I've been
there this is how you have to get there
I think that's a very powerful
combination if there's a real
relationship there because DeSantis can
learn from Elon who was very geeky and
and awkward and now can carry his own
with the media I know who else I you
don't hold that thing be good to be in
his ear a Joe Rogan I think a jobian in
in uh 100 so for example like let me if
I'm if I'm the Santa's campaign manager
let's just say let's go through the step
process number one is he making the
launch in the best possible way I don't
think there's a better way to make the
announcement I really don't think
there's a better platform for him to go
to to make the announcement than Twitter
spaces I'm 100 that's number one
nothing's above it okay let's look at
some of the next 10 15 moves let's let's
process the next 10 15 moves okay uh
number one uh in the 10 15 moves you got
to get on the Rogan podcast okay you got
to get on a Megan Kelly podcast you got
to get on the pbd podcast you got to go
to those three why Rogan and can
humanize you because Rogan's going to
bring you out the human side of you
you're going to talk and it's going to
be a great conversation Megan Kelly is
going to get the women who are not happy
about the decision you made for uh the
the six weeks because that was a big hit
oh yeah and she's gonna come at you
you're going to go show you're going to
go there and they can make up a little
bit on that too no you can't see his
humanness yeah he can come over here and
talk about uh how the business audience
can trust him how the entrepreneur's
capitalism as well as some of the stuff
that we've addressed over the last you
know 12 months uh uh and then from there
to me he's got to do ACN in town hall
he's got to do an MSNBC Town Hall he's
got to go on a view he's got to go to
the places he doesn't want to go why
because the other guy is going to go to
all those places for example do you
think Trump's going to do Twitter spaces
in the next three six 12 months 100 yeah
what do you think that Twitter space is
going to be with Trump and uh and musk
you think that that's going to be the
biggest Twitter spaces in the history of
Twitter it's going to shut it down by
the way a couple things to be thinking
about a couple things to be thinking
about I want you to go on YouTube right
now I always look at the stuff like this
go on YouTube and search the following
words okay search the words uh uh uh
DeSantis and musk type in the santis
musk take the and out yeah so then go to
filters to the top left go to today go
to today to yeah that's today and then
go to view count go back to filters go
to view count okay and now let's look at
how many people cared about the
announcement yesterday the numbers are
not that big by the way it so if you
look at 161
WPBF you got MBC 212 Bloomberg 5200 gold
of the Lord make that yeah exactly CNN
only 50 000 okay uh NBC only 30 000
Forbes only 83 000 DeSantis on MSNBC 69
100 and 2 000 on ABC 2800 that's 17
hours ago 2900 keep going lower and
lower 102 000 83 now somebody somebody
may say well Pat you got to go look at
Fox because I bet when they when they
said this guy was going to announce the
fox one probably has a million and a
half okay go to Fox's Channel okay go to
Fox news's channel
if you go to Fox news's channel and go
to videos okay and then let's go lower
and go to the part where they announced
the santis and musk keep going lower
keep going lower keep going lower keep
going lower okay right there the
sentence to announce can you zoom in
40 000 views
what are we maybe maybe that's not the
main one go back and zoom out to see if
there's any other ones maybe other a
little bit low okay how much is that one
25 000 views yeah keep going lower keep
going lower keep going maybe there's
another one keep going lower keep going
lower keep going Lord not that we're
already out of the day okay so so
meaning this is the point
if only
that few people are caring about the
announcement this says a couple
different things to me okay
one uh the the the the bit of an
irrelevance so far where people really
don't care because Dev in their mind
made up their minds the guy is going to
be Trump for the Republican side again I
may be wrong
two if if this is where you are you now
have to play the comeback game so the
comeback game to me this doesn't mean
it's over at all the comeback came to me
is you have to out Town Hall Trump you
have to out be sitting there with people
shaking hands doing combos you have to
go on the kind of a campaign a few
people have ever done
to show your face everywhere for people
to say this guy is strong this guy's
likable he's willing to sit down with
the opposition we all know he's
brilliant we all know he's smart damn I
love his wife and how they work together
I I totally relate to what she's saying
she's going to protect me as a mom we're
good to go but meaning the announcement
wasn't as big of a pop I want you to
think about this say the biggest
announcement you're ever going to make
in your life and you're gonna make it
with the richest man in the world
shouldn't it get millions it did not so
that's a little bit of a a little bit of
a concern there's nobody in the world
you could have made the announcement
what that's a bigger than Elon Musk so
tonight's Twitter Twitter spaces
on how it's going to be held
I wonder how many people are going to
log on I wonder how many people are
going to how many views it's going to
get and I wonder how many people are
going to get on there because musk is
doing it and I wonder how many people
are going to get on there because of the
Senators how he shows up today it's got
to be so important on how you prepare
meaning I'm sitting with him Casey I'm
saying babe tell these five jokes okay
it self-deprecate yourself a little bit
okay talk about you know what it is you
know about being a father how much you
love being that but you know you're
doing your best to be a great father in
your marriage and how much you love
America but self-deprecate a little bit
yourself if you can do that because
today it's really a Nixon opportunity
meaning Nixon was great on radio you
don't see the sentence's face tonight
it's Twitter spaces it's a good position
for him to be only his voice not the
face and reaction or anything there's no
visuals no Twitter space is only audio
it says so anyways that those are some
of the things I'm thinking about when it
comes down to this yeah go ahead well I
just want to say uh I disagree yeah and
I'm gonna tell you why I disagree we
have to understand this
DeSantis is not winning a general
election right now we're still in the
primary and I think that sometimes
people who do this and sort of like are
in this world in this media World in
this political world or whatever
sometimes we can be in a bit of a bubble
right and so I want to step out of the
bubble a little bit and we have to
realize that his pure Focus right now is
beating Donald Trump for the Republican
Presidential nomination it's not going
on scene it's not appealing to
Independence it's not trying to get
people from the left to come in it is to
beat Donald Trump to present himself to
Republican primary voters as the viable
alternative to Donald Trump so I think
that what he needs to do right now and
what he's doing is he has to get out to
where these people are so the view in
CNN and MSNBC and mainstream those are
not a concern until he gets the
nomination because those people hate his
guts already
so his team is making a calculation that
I have to go where my people are so I
don't know that these low numbers on uh
YouTube and I don't know that these
little numbers are indicative of a lack
of enthusiasm and I don't even know if
there needs to be a whole lot of
enthusiasm for the announcement outside
of this base the only thing he needs is
that base he needs enough Republican
primary voters to make the choice for
him against Donald Trump and then after
that that's when he goes to the gauntlet
of the mainstream news and one more
point that I want to make is that when
we talk about the Santas having to go on
here Joe Rogan the Megyn Kelly podcast I
think that as people that have a sphere
of influence and the sort of free
thinking conservative media world like
whatever you want to call it I think
that there's a responsibility for us to
ask these people tough questions as well
not to be like the view where we're
actively going out against you but to
ask real questions making Kelly has said
before on her show that she has been
inviting DeSantis on for months and he
won't take the invite because making
making guys is going to ask some
question of course you know and I think
that that's our responsibility you know
making Kelly responsibility Joe Rogan's
responsibility to ask them tough in real
questions
um but not you know to be attacking them
in the way that they know I don't think
she won an MSN no I don't think anyone I
don't think Joe's attacking I think
Joe's going to be the safest place for
him to go yes and and I again I think
Joe has the gift of making people like
you like he increases your likability
score I think Megan Kelly has women that
follow her that are going to be saying
okay if Megyn Kelly gives the nod
because Megan Kelly is not going to be a
trump supporter yeah yeah which is going
to be more DeSantis so it's a very safe
place as well for her to go to for him
to go to but uh you know again hopefully
you're right I think sometimes when
you're saying Trump's campus only people
around him that are telling him what he
wants to hear I think the same can be
said about the same time oh absolutely I
think that was the biggest flop of any
book launches in a history of
presidential candidates for him to come
out with the book and the launch did the
way that it did yeah I I can't think of
a a person who was at the number one
position or number two position for
president to launch the book as bad as
they did all he had to do with the book
launch tell us publisher wait three
months yeah let's launch it in June
let's launch it in may not let's launch
it in February everybody forgot you
either look you just made you forgot
that his book came out four months ago
came out and I didn't know that it did I
mean three months ago the book came out
it just it happened and then it kind of
disappeared I mean that's terrible bro I
didn't die I didn't go to anything I
don't know it should have launched right
about now yeah
you launched today on on the on the
Twitter spaces today's the day you
launched well again his biggest problem
is that he has a marketing problem
that's you know so he's gonna have to
address that and then back to your point
you're absolutely right uh he is focused
on the primary right now yeah the
general rules you focus on the primary
then you pivot in the general election
we all know that yeah he does have a
game plan an agenda remember the whole
whiteboard thing where essentially if
you look at the uh conservative base you
know one third of it is
Never Gonna not vote for Trump never
happening not happening whatsoever
another third of it all right is
potentially maybe like a quarter of it
potentially willing to go outside of
trump or DeSantis right Tim Scott Nikki
Haley Pence what have you so meaning
there's a chunk 50 or so that is quote
unquote right for the taking this is his
game plan so his intentions are he's
going to the to the run to the right of
trump he's going to say I'm more
conservative than Trump I have more
conservative values than Trump that's
not my opinion that is not really his
game you're right okay I don't think
it's a good good move for them that's a
terrible yeah that's Ted Cruz I don't I
don't want that's the Ted Cruz yeah I
don't want to hijack but you know uh in
in that conversation that that we were
having in the in the three hour that
three and a half hour dinner there are
some things about the space and there's
some things about the people that they
need that they don't get
yeah they do not get well wait what was
that again say that again I think that
there are some things about where the
space is right now we've gone a
conservative free thinking independent
whatever there are things about the
space that they do not get
um I agree there's things about the
space that they do not get because again
you're in a bubble the same thing you
said with Trump you're saying he's in a
bubble I actually think he's in a lesser
of a bubble than the santisism maybe
right I think Trump's bubble he's got
people around him that look he'll go to
UFC he has people like Dana White around
we think Dana's going to be like yes sir
okay what do you think about this hey
can I ask you a question uh what
happened on the thing with you and Elon
I mean let's let's hey what happened
with you and Rogan I talked to Joe the
other day I don't see Dana White being a
that guy you go on elk boys it's very
risky to talk to younger younger 20 30
year old boys and you're like yeah so
you don't ever know what those guys are
going to be asking you they're not like
proper Sean had any safe space so I
think I think believe it or not I think
Trump has
ee less protection than the Santa says
the sentence has been it's like a
fighter and by the way this is what's
gonna sound crazy I I see this guy as a
brawler
I totally see this guy if like this
guy's a brawler he's a fighter hey can
you guys honestly take those masks down
like why do you want you don't need to
do this take your masks off what are we
doing here I like that you know what
we're not gonna do that right now I like
that there's a part of that that'll and
by the way do you remember back in the
days people used to say America is not
ready for a president out of New York
you know Chris Christie we just New York
is not America we're not ready for
somebody that's going to be so bombastic
and well guess what what are you talking
about yeah America's ready for a guy
from New York so and this guy's not from
New York he's more proper he's a fighter
he's being protected a little too much
and you got to go fight some people that
annoys you and they're using your
fighter analogy I think the whole his
whole narrative for months now don't
forget he just won re-election for
governor of Florida November 24th that
was his Focus right
not out of um Charlie Chris God uh and
his whole thing was like listen speaking
of being in a bubble you know we're
focused on descendants because we live
in Florida yeah clearly based on
National Media or YouTube it's not a
main focus he's been focused on Florida
his whole numbers surprise you a little
bit but but again his whole thing is I'm
not in Canada yet and they're talking
about me so much I'm Trump's going
against me they spent millions of
dollars I'm not even a candidate I'm not
even a candidate but I'll tell you what
what this to speak to your fighter
analogy remember in uh Rocky and Apollo
Creed when they go out and then they do
their fight and he goes all right how do
we want to do this and Apollo just goes
ding ding the fight is on now as of
today Rocky was for the people DeSantis
is not yet coming across as he's for the
people Rocky won the people he has to
win the people listen
Ron DeSantis Casey whoever's watching
this if you watch this clip at all
Governor Ron DeSantis we're in Florida
because of you yes I got a
recommendation for you get away from
everybody and watch the movie Gladiator
and then go to the scene where Russell
Crowe asks I also want my freedom and he
says the magical words
win the crowd win your freedom you're
brilliant you're smart you're
intellectual you're intelligent you've
got a great resume you have one you have
not won their freedom you have not won
the people you have to do whatever you
can to win the people today okay not the
smart people in the room you know
sometimes you're like well I can sit
with anybody and I can beat them
intellectually that's not how you win
yeah okay you know I can sit there and
talk that's not you gotta win the crowd
you got to win the crowd we had a girl
years ago
when I got into the insurance space this
girl was the smartest girl in our office
it's 2003 okay uh she saw herself as a
Oprah Winfrey smart girl brilliant and
everybody would go through to questions
so some of the guys that I was training
would say things like this to me they
would say Pat I gotta tell you man I go
to her because she knows more about
insurance than you do I'm like that's
she yeah she knows more about products
than you do I said you're right go to
her
so they will go to to learn about
products but they would come to me when
it came down to sell
they would come to me when it was time
to promote they would come to me when it
was time to train they would come to me
when it was time to drive and guess what
I know about products as well but she
spent her entire life wanting to know
everything about the product and not the
people and then all of a sudden fast
forward 10 years later she's by herself
knows everything about products but
she's got nobody to train
and everybody wakes up and says oh my
God we thought that guy didn't know
anything about products but he won the
crowd nobody cares how much you know
about policy level at the Humane level
you can outschool any Governor any
Senator any Congressman anybody when it
comes down to issues yes but you got to
win the crowd and you have not won the
crowd yet that's my biggest criticism
you win the crowd you win your election
you become a president you are 10
million percent accurate I was hoping to
be 11 million percent of them well you
know my math isn't so good I'm trying to
win the people today because I'll tell
you why you see like in the in the
Republican Primary people like how did
Trump do it how did Trump do it well you
know they say you got to talk to people
to get a fifth grade level but they
broke down candidates and it was like
well uh Jeb Bush talks at a sixth grade
level Ted Cruz is at an eighth grade
level yeah and and that Trump is at a
third grade level and I don't mean that
condescendingly I mean he is talking
right to the people simple terms bill
the wall lock her up drain the swamp
these are messaging points that people
can chant get behind DeSantis as of now
has none of that and I gotta tell you
about Trump okay so you you guys met
Trump yes yes okay so
multiple times and the the amount of
Charisma that this person has is it like
you you people can see it and people can
see the videos of the routes or whatever
but the Charisma is off the charts
there's actually there's Christmas
there's extra Charisma this is somebody
that can go into a room he can talk to
billionaires he can talk to the guy
that's that's a cashier at McDonald's
and that is something they're these
intangibles right there are certain
things that you cannot teach there are
certain things that you cannot train you
cannot train the ability and you cannot
teach the ability that he has to connect
with the American people and one more
thing that I will say about Trump if
we're talking to Trump versus Santa
saying and this is what I think a lot of
people miss
there is now a Nostalgia factor for a
lot of people in the base when it comes
to the Donald Trump presidency because
when they look back at their actual
lives not what the media was saying not
what you know paid operatives and the
the Maga camp or the DeSantis camper
saying when they look back to their
actual lives their lives were better
their gas was cheaper their groceries
are cheaper they were making more money
and the money that they were making was
going further so now they feel the the
the results of this Biden economy in
their own lives and man I want to go
back to that yeah I remember what my
life was like Tom can I build you up for
a second I think what Tom said is almost
metaphorical okay I'm not going to touch
your tongue
what you said about the analogy how how
Europe you're a geek and you would go to
these Silicon Valley type things and you
saw the Reed hoffins of the world and
the Elon Musk of the world and the Peter
teals of the world and they were just
kind of these nerdy Tech guys getting
started suddenly famous great little
companies and now you look at them now
and they've been media trained in their
media savvy think about in front of
Congress a couple times exactly all that
just think about how long Trump has been
in front of the cameras and on stage
we're talking 40 years all right in New
York in New York and he's so and we're
talking to Santas we're talking four
years okay maybe so he's got some
catching up to do
anyway this is what I was saying to uh
no in relation to what you want to say I
want to get Tom last final thoughts and
we'll go to the next Story Goes I think
what everybody remember is it's baseball
season right now this feels a little bit
like spring training and in 60 days in
in August we're gonna have two uh all
candidate debates one is in Milwaukee
the other is in Simi Valley and they're
in August opening day Tom that is
opening day of the Republican and then
guess what happens nothing happens for
120 days until we get to January and so
what will happen in those 120 days well
if interest rates don't move the other
way people are all thinking about how
they're doing if there is a recession
and more layoffs to the end of the year
people are going to be thinking about
what they're doing there is a lot of
opportunities to talk to candidates over
those 120 days to say what's your plan
what's your plan it sucks now I know you
want to solve the vote for you but
what's your plan for 120 days from
opening day and it's going to get kind
of tough and it's going to get redundant
and a little boring
but then the first polls at the
beginning of January because it's a fact
that the because it's Iowa and New
Hampshire South Carolina so you have
Iowa which is now really a light blue
State now it's no longer red it is light
blue and then you have New Hampshire
which is very light red always
contrasting Vermont that is dark blue
and then you get South Carolina bright
red those happen in and I say that's
baseball playoffs that's when the game
really starts in January of those
playoffs but we're going to go through
just like the long summer of baseball
we'll see what's going to happen but
what is happening right now is pride
organizations are canceling events all
over Florida due to climate of fear
after State passes anti-lgbtq laws this
is an Insider story Pride events in
Florida are being canceled due to the
law and organizations organizers on
Saint Cloud cancel their events citing
the unsafe environment created by recent
uh laws targeting the lgbtq community
the decision followed the signing of a
bill by Governor Ron DeSantis that
imposes penalties on businesses allowing
children to witness adult life
performances with potentially sexually
explicit content other Pride events in
Tampa St Lucia Port St Lucie and Lake
County have also been canceled due to
concerns over this
MSNBC guests claims Florida is about to
be a terrorist state for black and lgbtq
people this is a mediaite story
Democratic strategist Aisha C Mills
appeared on MSNBC deadline and claimed
that Florida is about to be a terrorist
state for black and lgbtq people
praising the naacp's travel advisory as
extremely clever Mills expressed her
personal discomfort as a lesbian and a
black woman stating that she does not
want to have anything to do with Florida
and believes that many others feel the
same way she commented she commended the
NAACP for issuing the advisory and thank
them for their broad guidance and the
representative Brian Donalds criticized
the travel advisory as stupid and
without basis while Fox News contributor
Geraldo Rivera dismissed it as a Fear
mongering public Mercedes done so how
much of this what they're doing
are they trying to you know they're
realizing the scientists is potentially
going to be who he's going to be and
they're trying to Target him what what
do you think is and can they actually
make Florida terrorist States what do
you think about these two stories well
it's ridiculous look am I allowed like
what's the language okay look number one
like I'm a black gay dude um and Aisha
meals is full of [__] yeah all right
she's full of [__] and what's going on
here you have to understand there's a
lot of different things that's going on
Ron DeSantis is seen as so I I think
that the left is is more scared of Ron
DeSantis than they are of Donald Trump
just because they know how to how to
deal with Trump and they're not quite
sure how to do with the Santas right so
there's a lot of these this this
political stuff that is happening that's
sort of trying to make it seem as if
Florida is just this apartheid state and
and if you are black or gay or both or
whatever then you just live in this
constant fear and constant danger it is
completely ridiculous I've been living
in Florida for the past three years I've
been living in Miami for the past year
this is a great place doesn't matter if
you're black white gay straight whatever
Florida is just a great place to live
okay and so what this is all about
is the the
lgbtqia K plus plus the alphabet people
the rainbow Mafia right I don't I don't
identify with any of this I'm like I'm
just gay dude but they are they're
becoming this sort of um target market
for the Democrats right they want to
make them another victim group like
they've made black people a victim group
that they've tried to make Latinos a
victim group they want to make these
LGBT people like a victim group for them
so in order for them to be a victim
group for the left they have to push
their propaganda that says that you
can't live in Florida all of these laws
are bad all of this other stuff it is
completely ridiculous like it just is
not based on reality and when you look
at these quote-unquote anti-lgbtq laws
it is again [__] number one there's
no such thing as a trans child and a lot
of these laws are basically in laws in
Florida and other states it's basically
saying that we need to pump the brakes
on pumping
um young kids full of puberty blockers
and doing all these experiments that do
not have any long-term studies okay that
is not anti-el's BC or whatever that is
like just Pro Common Sense okay and so
look
I'm somebody like I'm a guy like you
know I watched RuPaul's Drag Race and I
went to Drag Brunch and all of that
other stuff it is Megan Kelly had said
the same thing on her podcast it had
always been just this fun thing for
adults to do in in it keyword adults
adults adults and this had never become
a thing that was oriented towards
children until recently in the past five
to seven years and I'll I'll say
something that got me in a little bit of
trouble when I said this
um on on other outlets what a lot of
people don't realize about the fact that
all of this stuff is now being targeted
towards kids the drag queen story hours
and in the transitioning of kids all of
this other stuff what you have to
understand is that the radical far left
queer Theory people okay that is where
all of this stuff comes from and the
fundamental goal for the queer Theory
people
um is the normalization of pedophilia
right so you have to understand that
that is where this is all supposed to be
headed that is their goal but the idea
that Florida is some place that is
um a not a great place that is not a
safe space that is somewhere that is
dangerous for me as a black gay dude is
fundamentally ridiculous it's complete
[__] and anybody with half a brain
uh will see the political machinations
at play here yeah Rob I couldn't have
said it better completely agree by the
way is there anybody that could weigh in
on this better than a black gay dude
living in Florida I mean hello you
couldn't even write this correct
yeah exactly like you can yeah this is
so nonsensical hyperbolic and
hypocrisy at its finest so I'm not a
black gay dude I'm just a straight white
dude but I'll give you a I've been
living in Florida for yeah over 40. I
thought you were going to come out for a
second yeah
this isn't that episode because today's
the day of announcement Ron made the
announcement I thought maybe you were
gonna stay tuned for tomorrow no
actually it was gonna announce that I'm
straight on this podcast
news so we convinced them y'all okay you
were telling us I've lived in Florida
for 40 years and if you know anything
about Florida uh Memorial Day weekend
which is this weekend yeah
black people from all over the country
come here for summer break yeah okay it
used to be Atlanta freaking whatever it
used to be yeah
she's been there done that great
bookstore yeah that's my type of books
but so I like how many black people are
gonna be like uh yeah yeah all that uh
all that uh LGBT Pride gay uh NAACP come
out it's like yeah I'm still gonna get
my free gun in South Beach yeah so it's
it's so nonsensical and then last week
or the last month was Pride week in
Miami of course zero issues no problems
on Sunday brunch have you ever been to
the on Ocean Drive
yes Rob knows it I mean they do that the
drag queen stuff so like
The Narrative is not matching reality
it's ridiculous and let me make a point
because you you brought it's really
funny that you brought this up so in
literally it I was going to Tweet about
this I was going to do a little video
about this Miami Beach has a pride event
Miami beats Pride this is literally
subsidized by the Florida government
they have all sorts of sponsors there
they were very expensive DJs that were
there um there was sponsorships from
Delta American Express there were police
officers there all of that other stuff
completely free to anybody that wanted
to go by the way oh yeah so Florida is
such a terrorist State yeah in in Ron
DeSantis is basically Stalin when it
comes to gay people right it's it's
ridiculous like it just does not pass
the smell test even for a second and
here's the thing about
um the the gay and lesbian vote I don't
say lgbtq and nobody should say lgbtq
because it's like it's just it's it's
ridiculous like most people we're
talking about gays and lesbians here
right
um in the last election they had found
that 30 of
gays and lesbians voted for Trump right
so that's a 70 30 split I personally
think that it's more because I come
across gay guys all the time at first
when I came out as a conservative gay
dude or whatever at first it's like you
know you lose all your friends
everybody's like oh you're a prior right
but now like I go to oh oh hey Rob like
you're that guy right yeah yeah I'm that
guy no now I understand what you're
saying oh this trans kid stuff is crazy
all of this you know this drag queen
stuff is crazy why there have to be kids
they're all of that other stuff so gays
and lesbians are more conservative and
people think especially you don't talk a
gay dude that's making 250k plus a year
you think this person is going to be
voting for Democrats absolutely not why
no they're thinking about taxes they're
thinking about taking communities same
thing everybody else everybody else
thinks it's identity politics oh it's
fine oh you're black
Democrat absolutely it's bomb words this
is Geraldo summed it up perfectly this
is a fear-mongering publicity stunt he
was in out Geraldo knows media he's been
around a long time he sees these are
just bomb words like when you point at
somebody and yell racist racist you know
it's distracting bomb words and what's
interesting Aisha Mills who is full of
crap as you pointed out she called it oh
that was extremely clever she didn't say
wow that's an important message to keep
people safe that's what you say if you
really think there's a problem that's
what you say If you think there is
really risk somewhere instead she comes
out oh that was very clever to say it
that way I thought that was very telling
it's like she she unveiled the whole you
know lunacy of of the issue look there's
a famous poet that once said for those
that are wondering whether they should
come to Florida or not to have a good
time this famous poet said get your
freak on my name is Missy Elliott okay
so if you're looking for coming to
Florida have a good time don't worry
about it come on down here she is right
and for those of you guys that have a
family and you want to come down here
and get your freak on in a different way
with your own spouse you can move to
Fort Lauderdale or Palm Beach or Boca or
ball Harbor right now we're looking at
properties all over the place we're
looking at Miami right now because we're
wondering what we're going to be doing
with the land that we're going to buy
we're going to buy the land here mayor
Suarez is a very very aggressive
recruiter and he's trying to talk to us
about potentially moving by Tim and to
Miami but we're we're gonna see what's
going to happen but Tom let's go into
the about life story here's about life
story so we this week I'm going to show
you guys a clip with Tom which is
classic I try to get Tom to do something
he was not too happy about Rob if you
can find this clip before we get into it
on Twitter uh uh just go to my account
story of the day so first I'll read the
story and then I'm going to show the
video but let's first go into the story
how Bud Light Blue at page 18 Wall
Street Journal story Bud Light the
popular beer brand faced backlash and a
boycott after sending a personalized can
to a transgender dealer we all know that
story The Boy kind of significant impact
on Bud Light sales which dropped more
than 28 compared to the previous year
that's a lot 28 that's a third in an
effort to recover the company plans to
include Bud Light in its sponsorship of
a veterans organization and focus on
television commercials highlighting
themes like football and country music
so for me one more in Dallas we're
standing at this beautiful hotel
Thompson we're at the suite all the way
at the top it's the corner Suite massive
Suite beautiful place and I'm trying to
be hospitable to Tom and here's how Tom
reacts very disappointing go ahead and
play the clip
stay in a penthouse like this all the
way at the top
you got to get Tom the right kind of
drink Seven can you please serve Mr
Ellsworth the proper drink I'm sorry
this was not set up
mourning us and take your uh no what is
it we can't see it no I won't even touch
the bottle what I can't see it what is
it Sam doesn't know the difference
are you joking Tom
just a beer
no it's not a beer you know how you make
Bud Light you know how you've been Bud
Light tell us you let a horse drink
Coors and put a bucket underneath and
that first filters the cores and that's
how you make butter wow you see that's
why you're the fence what is going on
with Butler what do you want to tell us
about life here well I I'm disappointed
um a little bit in corporate leadership
you know I do case studies look at
corporate leaders and stuff and how you
lead to turbulent times and right now
you've got the CEO Budweiser saying it
was one can it was one picture we were
we didn't have a contract well wait you
didn't have a contract did you really it
was a handshake agreement yeah exactly
right and it's a and there was one
person that was in the Marketing Group
and we shot her and we shot her boss and
we are getting back to where it was it
was and so you see what the CEO is doing
is trying to rinse responsibility off
the organization and and not only have
they thrown the marketing person and her
boss under the bus they're backing up
the bus going back and forth to make
sure they're dead and that is what's
happening it's really number one
the best thing to do is to say you know
what my team made a mistake and the buck
stops with me and I'm the CEO here and
you know what we're always trying to
Market and we're trying to Market to
various groups this was a freaking big
bonehead error and you know what we're
stepping back from it and this is how it
happened instead wait oh it was only one
can and it was only one one incident and
and there was only one person and she
didn't have permission from her boss
does that sound like a weak you know
leadership you do the Vault conference
you talk to leaders all the time pat is
that sound like a weak leader running
from blame or a strong leader coming to
the microphone you know you know what
the last thing you and I had a very good
conversation together for 45 minutes
okay and we're watching a Miami Heat
game he's giving me commentary I needed
help so he's kind of telling me watch
this place all this stuff but I told him
something last night I said you know in
life here's what mistake we can make and
you shouldn't make
you have to take a stand and have a
position
when you take a stand and take a
what happens next is there is opposition
you take a position there is opposition
position opposition great that's natural
hey I think Michael Jordan's the
greatest of all time you're a [__]
LeBron's the greatest of all time that's
opposition I think the Yankees are the
greatest organization of Steinberg are
you kidding me it's really the Dodgers I
think I'm a graduate the Muslim this
Christian did you know that that's the
opposition right okay Bud Light took a
position Their audience our male
white military
wanting to drink last thing they want to
think about is just politics they just
want to drink have a good time they love
America they want to go to a bar it's
not expensive beer they don't ain't
gonna have a good conversation most
people when you think about Bud Light
you think about a great conversation in
the moment you shared with a friend
right then these guys try to increase
their ESG score
and Bud Light Anheuser-Busch ends up
having a perfect ESG score okay one of
the best ESG scores in America do you
know what but do you know what they just
did the ESU score organization came out
and said I don't know if you saw this or
not they came out and they said
uh lgbtq uh group slashes
anheuser-busch's perfect rating they had
a perfect rating after backlashing
backtracking on Villa Mulvaney's Bud
Light controversy so what are they doing
now now they're backing up and they're
saying yeah I don't know if we you know
support what they're doing out they went
from a perfect score of 100 only 20
companies I believe had the perfect
score of 100. so here's what Bud Light
did you you already had your loyal
audience that's been loyal to you for
decades but you also wanted to win over
the CEI corporate Equity index score and
increase that you know what happened you
lost both not only did you lose your
customers but you lost the people that
you were trying to please that's what
happens when you conform people see
through it and they say it's [__] we
don't like what you stand for you don't
have a backbone dude I'm stepping away
so they lose 28 you know who gained 28
all the other guys course and everybody
else your customers went elsewhere and
for the I you know America pretty
forgiving so I think eventually they're
going to get over it and kind of be like
yeah whatever but it's going to take a
minute and the only way they can do it
is by firing the current CEO firing the
current CMO firing the VP of Ops showing
the fact that you fired everybody in
that department making a public
announcement that we don't care about
our ESG score our CEI score our di score
if you don't do that those people are
not coming back but if you do do that
and you replace them with a better CEO
better VP of marketing Better Boy
they're going to come out and say Here's
what I'm I love America here's what I
believe in and look we just want to make
good beer but let's make great beer for
many many years that's what we want to
get back to if you show that you don't
care about wanting to please these guys
I think customers will show back up but
that's going to take a year or two to do
100 and Budweiser USA is owned by
Anheuser-Busch USA is owned by inbev
which is a giant bear conglomerate that
also owns Stella Artois and many other
Corona and many other things
what inbev needs to do and says we
didn't buy you to pee in the pool we
bought you to keep growing as one of the
dynamic brands that is that lines up
like Coca-Cola and others with the last
hundred years of Americana it's a very
American iconic brand and inbev needs to
do exactly what Pat just said said you
you and you you're done we bought you
not to do this and you guys have just
puked on your own shoes this is over so
so here's the thing so I want to give a
little bit more context of this this
actually falls in line with something
I'm launching in the next couple of
weeks so everybody like go to
stopwoke.com you you'll see what's that
woke stopwoke.com put it in the
description comments that's great that
you got that so so here's the thing and
a couple of in a couple of weeks we're
going to launch what I'm calling the
corporate fairness index okay so stop
woke has partnered with the Rainey
Institute for Public Policy in DC we've
actually come up with methodology we're
going to announce the top five wokeus
companies in America we're also creating
a curriculum we're also creating a
curriculum yeah to go into these
corporations and to say okay this is
what you do to sort of get away from
this what people don't realize about
this Bud Light thing and what people
don't realize about the Dilemma of
anything and all of this other stuff is
that the Human Rights Campaign they have
something called the corporate equality
Index this is a grift they have shaken
down these corporations for the past 20
years the Human Rights Campaign calls
itself an LGBT advocacy organization it
is a far left
um Democrat Super PAC at this point that
gets 45 million dollars in Grants and
contributions in 2020. I personally know
for a fact that they have shaken down a
major Bank to the tune of nine figures
when they threaten them with dropping
their sword their score so Bud Light had
to do this in order to get one 100
rating on this corporate equality index
which is something that the HRC puts out
so the only way we can stop this like we
can talk about corporations or to work
all of that other stuff what we need to
do is number one
go into these corporations
um de-incentivize the importance of
something like the corporate equality
index and give these corporations an
off-ramp give them an off ramp to say
you know you can do your diversity and
all that stuff that's fine but also you
have to
um you have to sort of appeal to the
other side of the aisle as well so we do
not stop the fight against corporate
wokeness until we de-incentivize the
importance of the corporate equality
index that's why I'm launching the
corporate fairness index in a couple of
weeks
um we're going to be doing a lot of
stuff about that there's a lot of
companies that are very interested in
this and I believe that as a consultancy
um this is an Emerging Market these
companies and these corporations want an
offering they want a way out I'll tell
you I love it and by the way you know
who funds uh the HRC
Democrats open Society Foundation
Society he gave him 100 million dollars
in 2012. we're not even talking recently
100 million dollars in 2012. uh but go
ahead we're gonna say and one of the
things that um is I'm going I'm
literally going to the swamp tomorrow
you know I'm hitting up donors and I'm
doing these presentations all this stuff
so when I'm hitting up donors um
especially conservative leaning Mega
donors for
um organizations like stopwoke that are
doing this stuff that we're we're
building this this corporate fairness
index up and we're going to do this work
the first thing that they say is oh well
don't we already have this don't we
already have that will I give to this
politician I give that to politician
when you said that the Human Rights
Campaign is funded by George Soros and
his open borders Society open whatever
Society
the left these people fund all kinds of
organizations to the tune of billions of
dollars and we don't have very many
things like this on
um the right that are things that are
you know advocating for our agenda and
the reason why is that we have a donor
base you know as conservatives that are
so consumed with get this politician and
get this all this other stuff the change
that needs to happen in this country and
this last thing I'll say I know I've
been going on a bit of a tangent the
change that needs to happen in this
country is a cultural change it will
start with the culture and the
politicians will follow it is not the
other way around and this is what people
need to get I love it this is what I'm
going to tell you.com we got it all over
the place Rob respect to you yeah
appreciate that can we get a little
sneak preview of the top five most
companies give us something to work with
here guys I do not want to spoil
anything I got a couple places that have
the exclusive uh one place that has the
exclusive I will say that these are
companies I know that the the top five I
know two in the top five are household
names household names uh so so I hate to
disappoint you but what we did is the
last uh three months we've been trying
to increase our ESG score and our CI
score and this is what I'm here yes no
no this is what we did yesterday if you
want to if you want to play this clip uh
to try to do it
yeah who knows hey guys what's up Pap
what's up guys oh my God
what's up look at that
chicken legs
oh my god get it boy look at this
line right now
holy that's a good look that's a good
you just increase our ESG score you're
amazing I love you guys
it's crazy the heat was walking around
like that all day yesterday in the
office I'm like he comes in I'm in the
conference I'm like bro what are you
doing
he's like we're doing a skit I'm like
okay makes sense all right let's go to
the next story your time Jamie Diamond
warns souring commercial real estate
loans could threaten some banks and by
the way when he says that uh
interpretation uh we're about to buy
some more bags exactly
so JB Morgan Chase uh raises concerns
about commercial real estate loans
cautioning that certain locations office
properties construction loans could pose
prompts for banks Diamond States the
offside in this case will probably be
real estate it could be very isolated it
won't be every Bank despite historically
low loan defaults Diamond highlights the
impact of rising interest rates and
changes in a working environment
on commercial buildings especially in
markets like San Francisco he believes
there will be a credit cycle stating my
view is it will be very normal with the
exception of real estate Diamond
advisors Banks to prepare for higher
interest rates
urging them to plan for rates going as
high as six or seven percent that's not
something people in the real estate
business want to hear Tom what other
Insight do you have on this story here
well let's let's take it from uh from
the CEO office in the penthouse and
we'll take it all the way down to your
house first of all let me translate for
Jamie Diamond I I read it and um I was
able to translate it there are some
failing banks that have some furniture
that will look great in my office and so
it's basically what's about to happen
the um it's basically uh
for the last nine months JP Morgan has
been
basically like Batman that when Janet
Yellen and the FED are in trouble with
banks and failing and everything they
turn up they turn on the the bat
Spotlight and Jamie Diamond comes to the
rescue and helps them pick up the pieces
of these banks by taking Parts
assimilating them into JP Morgan and
then the rest of the things the um the
investor the excuse me depositors ended
up being protected by the federal
government because the deposit that was
beyond FDIC limits the government took
care of it but what diamond is saying
here is that the he's saying it without
being inflammatory the banking crisis is
not over because the interest rate
crisis isn't over and we all know what's
happening commercial real estate it's
getting rough and Rob do you have I sent
you a follow-up email which was the
mortgage highest rate since early March
take a look at this PPD
um for people if you happen to be
driving and you can't see what's on the
screen right now the it's a chart
showing the interest rates and we had a
bump up at about 6 and and three-quarter
percent in February now we're about to
have another bump up after we came off
the spike which was October November we
were above seven about seven and an
eighth and so the interest rates and
homes are not going down even though we
talk about the FED that maybe um German
Powell has been up to see the
cheerleader for the last time this year
and uh interest rates are going to be
flat what's really happening right now
is the interest rates and mortgages are
actually ticking up a little bit and the
houses are still not moving and we're
going to be a lot of headlines over the
course of the summer about things going
on in banking so it's still going to be
tough for people to sell houses this can
be tough for people to get mortgages in
new cities if your job moves and you're
laid off and you have to go somewhere
and so it's uh it's going to be a long
hot summer and you're going to see uh
Jamie dimon and JPMorgan Chase get
bigger because there are going to be
some small banks that were highly
exposed to commercial real estate get
clobbered is there any names
um I have some names next week but um
it's not any big names are out there
there's regionals see there's regionals
that may do really well like an indie
Mac that does really well in
Indianapolis and so they did a couple
large buildings in Indianapolis and now
those buildings have low occupancy rate
a troubled mortgage and that's what
knocks over a bank that is serving the
local commercial Market because local
commercial banks are tied to local
commercial politicians tied to local you
know downtowns that are getting built
the National Banks have less clout and
interest on those than they have in
broad-based consumer things if you're a
buyer right now commercial real estate
are you are you buying now are you
waiting six 12 18 months what would you
recommend on the commercial real estate
side
um
[Music]
you know the the Oracle of Omaha says
when it's raining outside run outside
with a wash tub and I think by the end
of the summer it's going to be raining
hard in commercial real estate and if
your business is in a position to move
up or you're able to grow or take
advantage of space I think you're going
to have opportunities to do it right
around Labor Day
interesting Peabody what's the Fallout
from this because I believe what was the
bank that chase acquired was it first
Republic I think there was they had 80
something branches and I don't know
eight to ten States they acquired that
Silicon Valley some of the branches took
some of the loan assets that were still
good began to service them and then you
got Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank where the other two Banks they were
taken over by the FDIC I want to say so
walk me through the the mindset of Jamie
Diamond you're just kind of sitting
there like all right
let's see which one of these bad boy
Banks Regional Banks we're gonna we're
gonna acquire next and then what are the
ramifications of that when these
mid-sized Banks Regional Banks shutter
and then all of a sudden we're back with
these four big Mega Banks how does that
affect the economy I can I can draw a
picture for you really easy it's really
easy to see
um let's spin back 15 years and look at
our cell phone choices and I'm gonna
give you some names that are gone
singular ATT when it was smaller Nextel
Sprint
um GT mobilenet uh and then you also had
the ones you still have now you had Bell
Atlantic mobile before it became Verizon
um and you take a look at that now look
at the consolidation you have four
choices now you have Independence
um that are you know the small ones the
phones for the elderly phones for people
and fixed income and then you've got
T-Mobile which now owns Sprint and
you've got Verizon and you've got ATT
what are your other choices you got
cricket cricket is one of the small ones
to serve a certain populous the same
things happening in banking what you saw
happening in Mobile phones is what is
happening in banking what you saw
happening in cable TV remember you had
all these different choices and all of a
sudden well you got a dish and you got
uh
um uh director of TV on satellite and
then you got whoever's got the cable in
the street probably Cox or Comcast and
suddenly you didn't have very many
choices Ott democratized that as long as
you get internet to your house you can
choose anything but um the same thing is
happening how will that affect the
average consumer if they're like all
these banks are being Consolidated I'm
left with only four choices well on my
podcast I pointed out that I said look
you know if you have a local bank that
really serves businesses well and you
have a first name basis and they give
you a little you know all kinds of loans
and support for equipment make the
relationship there but also have an
emergency account with money in it and
make one major payment a month maybe
you're building rent and have that with
Chase or with B of A good feedback every
month every Monday morning at what time
11 30 11 30 Eastern Standard Time
uh next story here looming existential
crisis for cable news this is a
Washington Post story cable news
declining influence and troubled
business model are evident as TV
viewership drops and Court cutting
accelerates the recent CNN town hall
with Donald Trump Drew just 3.3 million
views highlighting the industries
wanting power according to research
firms cable subscription have declined
from 70 percent
just seven years ago 2016 to under 40
percent today that's massive in a short
period of time despite the decline cable
news networks remain profitable due to
license fees paid by cable operation
operators however as cable subscribers
continue to decrease license fees may
become unaffordable for operators posing
a threat to the financial foundational
cable news while Networks
have ventured into digital platform
streaming services and apps have yet to
match the popularity and profitability
of traditional cable the future cable
news is uncertain with the industry
grappling with challenges and adapting
to streaming and appealing to younger
viewers this is pretty wild that that's
taking place Rob what are your thoughts
on this I have lots of thoughts on this
you know I'm somebody that operates on
both spaces and not a lot of people do
right because some people that are that
are in the cable news world are just
there and then some people that are sort
of in our world are just here so I've
been able to sort of negotiate both
spaces they really are two different
things the fundamental problem that I
see with the cable news networks and and
you can they're interchangeable at this
point you can switch out any of them is
that number one it is an older older
older audience right and so they are not
making the Investments talent wise
they're not making the Investments
infrastructure wise they're not making
the Investments content wise in order to
bring that age down they are more
focused on keeping the older audience
that they have right now than they are
in trying to build up the younger
generation of eyeballs and that doesn't
mean that you take a 32 year old and and
put them on cable news like that doesn't
matter a lot of the people for me a lot
of people that follow me on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at Rob Smith online
but a lot of people that follow me would
not see a lot of my cable news Clips if
I did not you know package them up and
post them on my social media this is a
huge problem now what I think is going
to happen uh is that maybe in the next
12 to 15 years when places like uh value
teammate are built up in places like
um DW like all of these content hubs you
know these people are gonna you know see
their declining relevance and they're
just gonna start gobbling these
companies up right but yes they are
becoming less and less relevant because
the people that are the youngest people
that come up to me on the streets or
that are my enemies or whatever like
they're finding me on on Insta they're
finding me on on Tick Tock you know
they're finding me on YouTube they these
people don't know what cable news is and
I think that as media people again we
live in this bubble where we give these
networks kind of like a lot more
relevance than I think that they have to
people that do not live in this world
because people that do not live in this
world could care less uh they're on
their phones you know they're following
their people on Twitter insta Facebook
YouTube whatever
Adam yeah I mean if you just look at
these numbers it's almost shocking if a
company if you if you did any company of
Tesla you know JPMorgan Chase pick a
company Amazon Apple the list goes on
and on if you said that
they've the cable subscriptions have
declined from over 70 of households as
of 2016 to now under 40 today okay
what is that 40 drop give or take it's
massive yeah massive yeah okay now let's
go five years from now if it's at 40 now
using that same math now you're at 20
yeah at what point are you just
completely out of business and bankrupt
it's pretty shocking and I love how they
say here the future of cable news is
uncertain what the industry grappling
with the challenges and adapting to
streaming and appealing the younger
viewers uncertain it's only one thing
I'm pretty certain that it's completely
in Decline well it's only one thing only
one thing is making cable news people
stick around YouTube
Sports so what Phoenix Suns did if you
can pull up Phoenix Suns Phoenix Suns
are moving away from relying on media to
control them and cable they're launching
their games to be played on an Ott
they're on Ott the sun do you realize
what will happen if these guys succeed
if they go away whichever everything you
need to know about the sun's New Media
deal and the mbas RSN problem so if
these guys get away and they say if you
want to watch the sun's play 9.99 a
month okay if all of a sudden a million
people in Phoenix or Nationwide that
like the Phoenix Suns pay 9.99 a month
or whatever the dollar amount is
now they're making 120 million dollars a
year off their Ott and they don't need
to put that anywhere on their own rights
if ESPN wants Clips they got to buy it
if other people on the clips they got
there's certain benefits that you get so
Sports is holding people uh within the
cable network once Sports goes and these
YouTube NFL deals these you know Spotify
if they do something they're not right
now if Twitter picks up something with
sports if gradually this happens
unfortunately cable news will be
newspapers very quickly and they'll have
to transition now don't get me wrong
this doesn't mean they're going to be
done done some of these guys behind
closed doors are working on you know
creating their stuff moving their stuff
from a cable to Ott you know fox is
doing Fox Nation CNN try to do CNN plus
where Kerry Lake wanted to do the
interview with CNN I don't know if you
remember that or not there's some of
these things that are out there but uh
we'll see what's gonna happen Tom any
thoughts on this yeah you can also see
that that although I think Pat and I
both agree that the NBA is not a very
good product right now
you also see things happening for
instance
um I believe it's important Trailblazers
they're the first NBA team that the
classic thing was a notable sportscaster
doing play-by-play and then maybe a
retired player or someone who's
incredibly respected in the game doing
uh you know side by side color
commentary well Portland has actually
put a stats guy there and what they're
doing is they're putting small stats
things out there that appeal to the
younger audience it's more likely to
play fantasy sports and they are the
first NBA team that part of their
broadcast team as they do Ott is like a
side-by-side stats guy so not only do
you see it going away from Main Street
the Bally Sports is just you know the
mother of invention is Crisis and the
ballet Sports crisis is giving
opportunities for Phoenix Suns to do it
their way and what the Portland
Trailblazers are doing with their
with their with their stats guy and I
think how it's being broadcast is
changing as well as where it's being
consumed I'm actually a little
disappointed myself that when you said
what they're what they're doing you know
what's changing this and you said Sports
because I'm that guy I don't have cable
I don't I haven't had cable in years
yeah I do I watch everything on YouTube
but I do want to watch Miami Heat go to
the NBA finals when they beat the
Celtics eventually and I done exactly
that I pay for YouTube TV and I figure
out ways to basically maneuver the
system just to watch the Heat game but I
refuse to pay 9.99 a month for basically
stuff that I don't watch right and I do
believe that the NBA is a good product
these days despite everything that
happened in the bubble I I disagree with
Tom by the way I think it's going to be
a better product when LeBron retires and
when LeBron Carmelo Chris Paul when
these guys retire I think the new age
players I like more than this vocal age
of players that kind of messed up the
game a little bit and you know guy as
big as him has become the greatest
flower of all time I made a
recommendation the other day for master
class to hire LeBron give them a few
million dollars to teach a course on
flapping I actually think it would do
very good with the new age people but
that's a completely different
conversation next daily wire okay who is
growing uh month in month out will
stream all shows on Twitter is what
they're saying this is a hill story
the daily wire Promenade right wing
Media company will stream all of its
shows on Twitter starting May 30th
aiming to expand its audience according
to daily wire's CEO co-ceo Jeremy boring
the overwhelming amount of positive
feedback from our advertisers and
audience signals tremendous opportunity
to move comes as conservative media
personalities increasingly turn to
Twitter seen at is it it is the platform
that refuses to engage in content
censorship based on politics former Fox
News host tuck across and announced
bringing his program to Twitter and
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis plans to
formally announce obviously we know that
the daily wire multimedia content
featuring fire breathing conservative
commentary covers politics pop culture
entertainment Matt Walsh apparently who
on his YouTube channel was saying he was
making around a hundred thousand dollars
a month and he had something that he put
about the trans or the drag shows he was
going against it he got a strike and he
says you know what if this is what you
guys are doing we're moving away from it
so what are your thoughts about daily
wire choosing to take all of their
talents big names Shapiro Peterson
Candace Owens Matt Walsh I got a lot of
good guys there to Twitter
huge massive it look it cannot be
overstated the importance of this move
right now and DW was ahead of the curve
with a lot of this stuff because they
started doing you know their full video
podcast and you want to talk about daily
wire for me is somebody that is sort of
you know looking to venture into the
video podcast space now I look at a
Candace Owens podcast it's like this is
what a video podcast should look like
this is what it should be this person is
on point she looks fantastic every day
it's culturally relevant it is all of
these different things so when you take
these things and put them on Twitter as
the full video element what this is
saying is that Twitter and Elon musk's
moves remember the new CEO of Twitter
Linda yaccarino what did she do before
that she was head of AD sales at NBC
Universal they are turning Twitter into
a hub for video content and they have
not even started to talk about how
they're going to be monetizing that yet
outside of subscriptions and so this is
what I say and I was saying in one of
you guys before you came to the podcast
fast
on Twitter it is not going to be enough
to just say [__] in order to get a
following at this point nowadays like
maybe you could have before uh maybe a
little bit right now yeah you can just
hop on Twitter and start saying things
this is going to be become a platform
for high quality video content for
people that know how to articulate
themselves on camera for people that
know how to put that video content out
there and we talk about the decline of
cable news and we talk about the fact
that Matt Walsh cannot say
um factual things about quote unquote
transgender youth on YouTube without
getting completely demonetized on
YouTube Twitter is the new platform so
they're ahead of the curve they were
ahead of the curve two years ago when
they started creating and producing
these these podcasts I I did Candace's
podcast a couple of times
um back when they were doing sort of the
like the panel format and then they kind
of switched it to where it's just her
and I think that that format works a lot
better I think it's a lot stronger but I
think there's a size seismic move Tom
I think and I just looked up something
here I want to grab a couple dates I
think the move of her going to Twitter
is as big as when Sheryl Sandberg went
to Facebook Cheryl Sandberg is not
credited with making
um Facebook
um ad business she's credited with
making Facebook profitable it was
unprofitable until she got there and she
put the ad business and the associated
monetization programs in place and she
did so without diving in and changing
what was on Facebook the product guys
were some excuse me the product
individuals were responsible for that it
led by Zuck himself and I think that
that's what's going on here I think that
she's looked at it this is how they're
going to monetize it and that you know
Elon Musk knows what he wants to do with
the product he knows what he's adding to
the product and I think he's been pretty
sensible about it so I I think this is
as big as Cheryl Sandberg going to
Facebook in 2008 she made the company
profitable in short order and then they
put her on the board of directors in
2012. well I'll let me just give kudos
to you because this bleeds right into
the pre to the previous story which is
speaking of meta Facebook Twitter
everything they were talking about Linda
yaccarino and Cheryl Sandberg the story
from Fox Business is reports of
Instagram making Twitter competitor
prompts comment from Linda yaccarino
you've said you've been very critical of
Facebook where basically all they do is
just copy what their competitors doing
or by their competitor and they just
make something different or or improve
upon it and that's essentially what
Instagram they're like holy [__] elon's
on to something Linda yaccarino the new
CEOs onto something we're just gonna
follow in their footsteps which
basically bleeds into the previous story
cable news is dying everything's going
on to digital media these days
everything's going on too YouTube
Facebook meta it's like the writings on
the wall and and Elon Musk is
essentially leading the charger it's
been there let me make a point about
Facebook I think that a lot of people
face Facebook is seen as dodgy and old
and irrelevant whatever so I've got
about uh closing up 500 000 followers on
Facebook I do videos on Facebook every
single day the ad Revenue that you can
make as an individual solo Creator from
Facebook videos people have no idea all
right people have no idea and the reason
that I'm so excited about Twitter as a
Creator because if I could be making
those Facebook numbers as myself me
personally as a Creator if I've been
making those numbers on Twitter game on
without risk without risk without risk
without risking yes that's a good point
because there are certain things that I
cannot say on Facebook there are certain
topics that I cannot go into on Facebook
but it's it's a huge deal
Linda your Carino game on everything we
need to know about Instagram's Twitter
clone due this summer I love that this
is great just game on I love that
competition yeah I love that answer she
gives right there okay so next uh story
we can go to let me see what story I
want to go into here
uh let's do
Tucker Carlson sends legal threat to
pack urging him to run for presidents
kind of interesting move here by his
lawyers
um
so Tucker Carlson's lawyer harmeet Dylan
has issued a legal threat to the draft
uh Tucker pack stating that Carlson will
not run for president 2021 under any
circumstances they'll warn the group to
seize its effort and vow to use legal
means to protect Carlson's rights and
supporters the draft Tucker pack
released a video on ad urging Tucker to
run for president praising his his
ability to combat leftists in both
parties parties and comparing him to the
late Rush Limbaugh Dylan responded on
Twitter declaring that the pack was
unauthorized and criticizing Newsmax for
airing the ad she warned donors about
being deceived and urged them not to
contribute to the pack this pack is
unauthorized fruitless to contribute
getting ripped off they owe their
viewers better than this rap look it's a
scam pack and obviously it's a scam pack
and Harmony knows harmed is a deeply
deeply intelligent woman so she knows
what's going on here and what a lot of
people don't understand about the
political world is like number one it's
full of grifters uh and it's full of
people that that are running hustles and
running grips and so you got a bunch of
people probably nobody knows who is
behind this scam pack but a bunch of
people that had enough money to put
together to to you know run ads on
Newsmax and they're basically saying
we're going to use Tucker's name and
we're going to bring in all of this
money nobody knows who these people are
nobody knows where this money is going
whatever it's a scam hermeet saw it
Tucker saw it and they're like they want
to put it into it and it's just normal
is this common this has happened oh my
God in the swamp cut oh my goodness is
this are they trying to is this a an
organization that sincerely wants to
help Tucker run or no they're just
trying to make some money I believe that
these people are trying to make money
and they're trying to use the biggest
name in in our space probably one of the
biggest names in America to do it this
is what Sebastian Gorka was talking
about yesterday with Trump and how
basically the parasites just basically
yeah
and just trying to siphon off money from
Trump World they are political
consultants and if it's an even year
even numbered year they make even more
money yep and they make money whether or
not their candidates win or lose that's
what people do not understand about the
swamp like the pollsters I don't have to
be right yeah they don't have to be I
just have to be
retained yeah these people are scammers
they're grifters the swamp is full of
these people and they will take a big
name and they will use that name to make
money because the the and this is what I
don't like about this entire situation
is that they literally they
underestimate the intelligence of the
audience of the Maga base of whatever
and in their minds in the minds of some
of these scammers the Maga base is a
bunch of Rubes
um to be grifted
interesting all right well
um I can tell you there's a lot of
people that would like to see the guy
run but I know that's not what he wants
to do he wants a different life if he
did I think he's got a big follow and I
actually think it would bump into the
number two spot really overnight I think
he's that powerful of a guy and likable
because remember the key word is what
winning you win the people you win your
freedom he's one people he's one people
it's the hardest thing to do okay next
story China Taiwan tensions could grip
2024 elections as musk Buffett and dalio
sounds alarm this is a CNBC story
influential Business Leaders such as
Elon Musk Buffett and dalio raising
concerns about the escalating tensions
between us and China over time on with
implications for 2024 election musk
emphasizes the inevitability
of the situation and its adverse impact
on global companies while Buffett has
divested from Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing companies due to
geopolitical concerns Dalia warns of the
risk of a war-like scenario between the
two superpowers the issue of Taiwan is
becoming a focal point in the political
landscape with Republican contenders
like Rhonda Santos Glenn yonkin and John
Bolton highlighting the need to deter a
potential Chinese invasion of the island
lawmakers are introducing legislation to
counter China's growing influence the
2024 election cycle is expected to bring
increased anti-chinese rhetoric and a
focus on addressing China's actions Tom
well what's really interesting is you've
been listening to this podcast long
enough you knew that a year ago we
called this we said that what was going
on in Taiwan was about global market
share of chips and to influence chips
and to put spyware on chips that's what
this is about this is not about we want
to right the wrong because we sent chain
kaishek to the Isle of Formosa later
named Taiwan and we want to get our
property back fact that is the political
Spin and that's part of the spin that
comes out of uh the the People's
Republic of China government if you take
a look at this chart we showed this
before and it hasn't changed this is the
market share of advanced semiconductor
Manufacturing in the world the world
look at Taiwan and look at South Korea
Samsung that is almost 80 percent of the
world and we've seen announcements
coming up because people are waking up
to this and realize it's not about China
taking back Taiwan because it's their
beloved Island and Homeland they want
the chips and so when China you you saw
that um uh we covered on podcasts about
three weeks ago right Apple made an
announcement they were making a deal
with India to manufacture iPhones in
India now Apple's announcing they want
to make a deal with broadcom to get
chips you also see that now uh Buffett
divested himself the tsmc there it is
right there Taiwan semicon conductor
Manufacturing Company Buffett was an
investor in the largest chip maker in
the world he has pulled back why it's
risk it's full risk that's what's going
on here and in the election year this is
a business story this is a foreign
policy story and this is an inflation
story because what's about to happen and
you you see uh challenges that U.S
companies will have getting permits to
build what's called a Fab it's a chip
Fab when you hear that in local news
that's a factory so if you hear a chip
Fabs coming to town that's good that's
usually a lot of jobs making chips here
in the United States but that's what's
going on in Taiwan everybody is woken up
to something that we were saying here on
the podcast a year ago and now you even
see apple who's cozy with China saying
yeah I need Manufacturing in India I
need chips made elsewhere because
they're all starting to sweat I'll just
add to this you know part of the
listeners or everyone the the shout out
to the value chainers that that listen
to what we talk about here if there's
one thing I've learned since being a
part of the pbd podcast for three years
is just can't understate the situation
that's going on with China Okay so
yesterday you did a poll
uh you know major concerns what what do
you what should uh campaign uh campaigns
be about you'd put Ukraine you put
Epstein I think that was the whole thing
you know immigration Health Care
everyone can give their top five here's
what I will tell you and I'll speak in
very plain language whatever candidate
puts China relations in a top five
scenario that is exactly where I'm going
to be gravitating my vote for because it
does not get spoken about I know Trump
did China and everything that happened
with that but
it's such an important situation that's
going on in international relations with
China and um it's it can't be
understated but also international
national relations as well but also just
in the amount of massive influence that
China has over our culture uh over our
entertainment industry over our business
sector all of that other stuff and
making our medicine and making our
medicine all of these giving us covet
yeah the uh the the fentanyl that's
coming into this country from China like
all of that stuff and even thinking
about
um Tech talk right and I'm not
necessarily in the band Tick Tock thing
but you have to think about uh what are
these images that are being put through
this platform and that are being
disseminated to the Youth of our country
okay
um divisive stuff you got people dying
in Tick Tock challenges all this other
stuff this is literally cultural and
psychological warfare
um to the level to which we've never
seen before and nobody wants to talk
about this stuff least of all a lot of
these
um these politicians who are in some way
owned by China I do believe personally I
don't know if I'm in trouble for saying
this I believe that that Biden is in
some way compromised by China
um something on that laptop like
something that is going on they've got
something on this guy okay and if we
don't have politicians that are that are
willing to stand up people that want to
leave this country people that want to
lead America into the Revival that this
country needs if they're not going to
stand up to China uh if they're not
going to stand up and start talking
about this I don't want to hear anything
they have to say so I'm with you on that
I've I think a lot of people are there
with you matter of fact talking about
Biden Hillary Clinton says Biden's age
is a legitimate issue people have every
right to consider it is what she said
during an interview at the financial
times weekend Festival Clinton addressed
Biden stumble
at the G7 Summit saying every time that
happens your heart is in your mouth
because these things could be
consequential is that a concern it's a
concern for everyone while other
Democrats have dismissed age-related
concerns Clinton expresses her belief
that Biden can be re-elected stating I
obviously hope he stays very focused and
able to compete in the election because
I think he can be re-elected and that's
what we should all hope for then Joe
Biden peddles his worst lie in front of
U.S Marines during Japan trip which this
is this is just uncomfortable it's
awkward it doesn't make any sense to
make this kind of a blunder during his
trip in Japan President Joe Biden
falsely claimed my son was a major in
the U.S army we lost him in Iraq
referring to his son Bo's death however
Beau died of brain cancer in America
Biden has repeatedly made this false
statement to portray himself as a gold
star parent and score political point is
the president's erroneous remark
occurred during an informal visit with
troops at Marine Corps Air Station
awakuni the traveling press Corps was
kept at a distance in the White House
did not release an official transcript
potentially allowing the error to go
unnoticed by the public the fabrication
has been previously called out including
by the New York Times Biden's false
claim diminishes the sacrifices of those
who died in combat and is seen as
Shameless and disrespectful equating his
son's death from cancer with the deaths
of soldiers in Iraq and Afghanistan as
deeply problematic play the clip do you
have the clip yes go for it
US Army
thank you thank you thank you thank you
that's just that's the go ahead shameful
infuriating I'm a veteran you're a
veteran as well
and look what this speaks to is the fact
that this is somebody that's obviously a
mental decline if you watch Joe Biden if
you watch his action you see him
stumbling up these steps you see him
tripping over the teleprompter if you
see him telling these outright lies this
is somebody that needs to be sitting
down on in a rocking chair on a porch
right now playing with his grandkids
this is not somebody that needs to be
the leader of the Free World but here's
the thing he has given a pass on this
over and over and over again because
when he lies who's gonna point it out
conservative media the New York Post et
cetera et cetera
um in mainstream media is just going to
pretend that this doesn't happen uh
they're just going to you know just just
sweep it under the rug
um and I want to get back to to one
thing about Hillary Clinton making the
remark about Biden's age and this is
going to be an unpopular opinion I love
Hillary Clinton I'm obsessed with her
she is so evil she is so unbelievably
evil she is my favorite super villain
she's like Thanos in The Avengers like
this is why I love Hillary Clinton so
much because she is just so
fundamentally evil and what you have to
understand about is super villain
that is fundamentally evil as Hillary
Clinton is that there is not a word that
comes out of her mouth that does not
have a political motive behind it she
knew exactly what she was saying right
there she knew that these remarks were
gonna go go viral and there is a point
there is a reason behind her talking
about Biden's mental decline
um in his cognitive decline and all of
this other stuff does that mean that
she's trying to get in I don't put
anything past Hillary Clinton at this
point
um does this mean that they're trying to
get somebody to run against Biden who
knows but the blood is in the water
Hillary Clinton that villain that that
evil human being right there saying this
um there's some political motivations no
doubt that she has an agenda every time
she speaks can we play this clip rub
yeah it's like is she running or is she
still pissed at him that's what I was
thinking when I heard it
raise the audience they're whispering
it's really that low time that happens
your heart is in your mouth because
these things could be consequential is
that a concern
well I mean it's a concern for anyone
um and we've had presidents who've
Fallen before who are a lot younger
um and people didn't go into you know
heart palpitations
um but he his age is an issue and people
have every right to consider it
but you know he has this great saying
and and you know I think he's right you
know he you know don't judge him by
running against the almighty but against
the alternative and
I am you know of the camp that uh I
think
you know he's determined to run he has a
good record that three years ago people
would not have predicted would have
gotten done uh he doesn't get the credit
yet that he deserves what is happening
out in the country by the way you know
but people people call a lot of people
as the greatest poker players of all
time is there a better poker player than
her she's she's got a two out of 10 and
she'll look at you as if she's got
pocket aces there's not a better person
in the game than Hillary Clinton she may
be the greatest poker player of all time
look guys this this is what I this is
what I skilled about she is a skill
policy she is this is what I tell my
audience all the time I'm problematic
out there I say this all the time these
people think that you are stupid
these people think that you're dumb
these people think that you do not know
facts these people think that you will
believe everything that they tell you so
when Hillary Clinton sits on that stage
and she talks about Biden having a good
record the expectation is that the
people that are watching her are dumb
enough to believe everything that she
says
by the way I wonder if it's comedy I
wonder if she thinks people are dumb and
I wonder if people actually buy what she
has to say next story here reparations
fight rowers as some cities push million
dollar payments to Black Americans are
Civic obligation and uh so the Battle of
represents intensifying the United
States this is a factional story with
discussions at the local state and
federal levels considering million
dollar payments to Black Americans
representative Corey Bush and
Progressive lawmakers have introduced
the reparations now resolution calling
for 14 billion Auto in reparation citing
a moral and legal obligation to address
the impact of slavery on black lives
reparations initiatives have emerged at
the municipal and state levels with
proposals for direct payments and
Assistance programs the California
reparations task force recommended 1.2
million dollar payment to eligible black
residents while even stand even Illinois
Evanston Illinois proved a plan to
provide twenty five thousand dollars for
home repairs or down payments to qualify
black residents
critics argue that reparations should
not be pursued and that they divert
attention from addressing critical
issues in Black communities what are
your thoughts on this look there's a lot
of thoughts number one no greater than
than Bayard Rustin who is a a legendary
icon of the Civil Rights movie he's one
of the ones that that co-founded uh that
co-organized the March on Washington and
this is Bayard Russian said this in the
60s uh and he said that his father was
not a slave nor was his grandfather or
something like that so he in in his mind
um reparations was a silly conversation
that we need to move forward from that
and so look you have to understand that
this is how the left uh this is what the
left does and this is what Democrats do
when they're trying to appeal to Black
Americans they have nothing substantial
to offer black Americans in terms of
policies uh they know that their
policies are actually actually
detrimental to the lives of
African-Americans so what do they do
every election year comes up here's the
handout here's some reparations here's
this here's that uh I don't know how
long people are gonna fall for it look
when I came out as conservative five
years ago and you know like you saw the
vice video and all that stuff and I was
like you know riding like you know black
people like we gotta wake up all the
other stuff five years later I do not
know because they somehow continue to
keep falling for this right and if they
continue to keep falling for this stuff
uh the Democrats are going to continue
to keep pushing it uh and and one more
point that I'll make about quote unquote
reparations
is that we have seen billions of dollars
that the federal government has given um
in terms of of programs to help Advance
African-Americans in terms of uh welfare
stuff in terms of all of this other
stuff and what has that really done all
right like it hasn't really done a whole
hell of a lot
um to benefit you know lower income
black communities across the country and
the issue that these communities face is
again not a political issue it is a
cultural issue I would the great Allen
West I was I was watching one of his
videos from my Facebook page yesterday
and he made this he he basically was was
debating what this college leftist and
he basically said the fundamental
problems in the African-American
Community are not going to be solved by
the government they're going to be
solved by the family structure why are
there no men in the house where are the
fan where where are the family structure
and the federal government has
de-incentivized
fathers in the household for the better
part of the past 40 50 60 years until
you fix that all of these problems are
never going to get fixed but Democrats
don't want to fix the problem they want
to pretend that they fix the problems
and they want to basically buy black
votes and pisses me off you know what
I'm gonna follow that up with some some
facts here and also we need to look no
further than our vice president who was
a proponent of the California three
strikes laws but that and it was three
strikes and then you spend your life in
prison so if your third conviction your
life in prison but
drug distribution
convictions counted as a full strike so
an 18 year old individual sells two
ounces of marijuana before it's legal
that's a strike and it was Kamala Harris
that pushed that in California and it
disproportionately you know imprisoned
for those relatively minor drug
distribution offensive I'm not talking
about fentanyl I'm talking about I'm
talking about pot talking about
marijuana grass
and she put an enormous amount of
men of color in the California state
prisons yeah Kamala the cop
s that's you ever see those memes it was
like Kamala Harris and the there's a
common little cop yep well let me ask
you
um I feel like you're a good person to
ask about this I'm actually here
representing all black people of course
that's why I'm using it as a
representative
that's that's exactly what I'm asking
this question
the uh I'll be over they're talking
about 14 trillion dollars in reparations
okay what's our GDP 22 trillion so we're
talking almost
two-thirds of our U.S economy GDP going
towards reparations yeah and also
dummies where is the money coming from I
want to go math here I'm not trying to
go
you know identity politics I'm not
trying to call anybody names here I want
to understand where's this money
actually coming from if you see
California the in San Francisco didn't
Dodgers go there recently they're
talking about giving people 5 million
dollar checks
how is this being funded fundamentally
it's like they they want it to come from
the tax dollars and here's the thing
like if you can we got a [__] debt
ceiling we can barely pay our own
freaking bills
in debt so where is this money coming
from yeah so I want you to understand I
want you to understand small thinker
over here they're trying to come up with
some trillions I want you to understand
the reasoning behind what they do it and
and how this also ties into sort of the
anti-capitalism anti-millionaire
billionaire rhetoric that they also try
to push to left this okay so on one hand
they're gonna say uh you are entitled to
reparations because you're so black and
you're so oppressed and the legacy of
slavery and the trauma and all that
other stuff and you're entitled to this
money you are not meant to think where
the money is supposed to come from okay
it's obviously going to come from from
taxpayer dollars it's obviously going to
come from the federal government right
but if you have a group of people that
are so anti-capitalist anti-millionaire
anti-billionaire whatever they're never
really good they're not thinking about
taxes my ex-bestfriend was a total
Bernie Sanders leftist he he was
perfectly thrilled to just take taxpayer
money these are not the people that are
going to be paying for that stuff right
and so
fundamentally if you get these people to
hate capitalism hate millionaires hate
billionaires and then say there's all
this free money that's going to be
coming to you because you're such a
victim and vote for us and we'll do it
of course it's going to be tax dollars
but they're not thinking about the fact
that this is little literally their own
money that they're going to be getting
back I think they have to be very
careful with this because do you know uh
uh you know when you when you look at
numbers like this do you know who the
first uh slave owner was in America
do you know the first ever slave owner
in America
do you actually know this it was a black
man it was a black man was Anthony
Johnson okay if you just type in first
Anthony Johnson
uh was the first slave owner in America
so this is kind of a you know when when
you go through the stats and you go
through stories and you go through what
happened and you go through the moment
with Don Lemon that he brought that one
lady on and he's asking about what do
you think about reparations yeah we
should go back to the Africans who are
the original you know slavery owners
yeah we really need to look into this
you know we really need to look into
this you know when you do things like
this uh it's it's a travesty what
happened to slavery listen man I'm
Armenian Armenian Genocide I'm half
Assyrian Assyrian genocide Greeks what
the Turks did to them it's it's it's
catastrophic it's it's terrible what
happened to those folks terrible what
happened to the Holocaust Holocaust yeah
nobody's sitting here saying any of that
stuff but uh I think the the way this is
going about is another thing to run for
election and I think it may get a lot of
people's attention to say can we win
some more African-American votes but
what you pointed out earlier is the gay
vote you were saying seventy percent
thirty percent voted for Trump in 2016
or 2020. it was uh I think those numbers
came out in uh 2020 2020. when you when
you think about that and then the
African-American vote for the longest
some Democrats have had 92 percent of
the vote since 1964 and it's gone to 88
84 so it's kind of going in a different
direction to say like I don't know what
uh the Democrats have done for me
nothing's really changed in my life when
I look like you just make my the top 20
30 cities in crime in America 27 are
written or driven by democrats so this
NAACP is sitting there saying hey you
know you should not go to Florida great
that's great why don't you talk so you
want people to go to the top 27 30
cities where 27 are Democrats and
they're not safe they can say these
things but the opposition argument is
going to be very easy to come back to
this I want to go to this other story
Rob can you pull up the story of what
happened in Iran okay this is this is
going to sound like it's out of a movie
it's not not this is not out of a movie
I'll send a link to you
on what just happened in Iran and if you
read this you're almost gonna say yeah I
don't know if this is true Iran has
hanged three people on drug charges amid
continuous continued criticism of its
execution practices and increased death
penalty sentences the three men
identified as shahab Mansoor nassab
Samad jervant and Saeed jervant were
hanged after more than 39 kilograms of
heroin they're saying that's what the
reason was and precursors and processing
equipment were confiscated with them
Judiciary website set on Sunday now
that's the story you're reading I'll
give you another story for you to read
Rob is this one I'm about to send to you
these guys that just went through this
they were anti-government protests they
were not supporting what they're doing
in Iran today and they spoke out about
it okay if you can pull up the link I
just sent you and Iran sits there and
says yeah this is kind of we got to make
a statement too so Iran executes three
men accused over anti-government protest
us Iran has executed Three Men and said
it was implicit in their deaths of three
members of security forces during
anti-government protests drawn
condemnation from rights groups and the
EU and risking further International
isolation uh uh so that story you pulled
up was a different story than this one
here Rob these are two different stories
were killed on Friday morning the
tasstem agency reported crowds had
gathered outside the prison where they
were being held on Thursday night as
rumors of their imminent execution grew
cultural figures inside and outside Iran
as well as family members had steeped
has stepped up a campaign over the past
weekend to Halt the executions on the
grounds that Iranian authorities had
failed to produce definitive evidence of
the men responsibly for the deaths of
two members of basig parliamentary force
and law enforcement officers on 16
November so it goes and goes telling
these different stories go on Twitter
now to see what's trending right now go
on Twitter to see what's trending right
now
go to Twitter and see on the right
what's trending King if you go to more
of them to show one of them should be
king Resort palavi is trending 16 17 000
on my screen it shows us number three uh
if you type in chingara's up however you
make it have a hard time spelling that
here's what's going on uh uh with Iran
when events like this happen Iran just a
year ago they had so much momentum so
much momentum with what was going on
you're seeing Reza palabi the son of
King Reza pallavi the gentleman right
there then I have at multiple meetings
together had multiple conversations
together people in Iran are starting to
worry about what's going to happen and
he is all over the place right now uh
talking about the fact that this is an
opportunity for Iran to be free we can
live in a country like America for
people that complain about America
when's the last time you went outside
and you said you know what they're
hanging three different people today
outside of DC yeah you know what
happened these guys talked against the
president and they're hanging out what
you're serious that would never have
just out of movies no that actually just
happened in Iran that those types of
things are still happening in countries
like Iran and uh I I you know it's such
a weird position for them to be in
because on one end parents want to see
Iran be free again but the fear of
getting their kids to be motivated by
this and they go out there and all of a
sudden like man I lost my son the parent
parent doesn't want to experience risk
and something like that
um so you can encourage them and say
look keep fighting I was like you're not
even in here to know how ugly it is what
do you mean keep fighting it is a
decision they need to be making but one
of my dreams is to one day take my kids
to Iran and show them where their father
was raised and I lived there 10 years
and how the history of this Empire that
they went from being where they were at
to the king building Iran into a place
where women finally had a voice but
it'll be interesting to see what happens
here I like seeing him all over the
place uh the son talking about this
there's more and more momentum going on
there but this was a tragic event that
just took place in Iran this week and
this is amazing perspective something
that um that really
um
clicked for me is when you shared the
story of when you first came to America
and your mom was watching just regular
news and the commentator was saying
something negative about our president
and what was her reaction she says poor
guy they're going to kill him tomorrow
because that's normal in Iran you don't
talk against uh uh you know presidents
that's just not something you do in Iran
you don't do that in America it's normal
in America it's a business model like
we're doing it today last two hours this
is what we've been doing I'd be homeless
otherwise you wouldn't be homeless maybe
five of us outside today so it's like
hey Rob's gonna say look I'm just
working here man I wasn't doing anything
I'm just having my drink and enjoying it
but it'd be me Adam Rob and Tom uh
outside of item in a statement being
made talk about us one more time that
would be the case in Iran okay so I'll
wrap up with the story from Wall Street
Journal get a couple commentary and wrap
this up uh uh does God exist only half
of Americans say a definite yes this is
a story on page 18 if you want to go to
it so only 50 of Americans are certain
about the existence of God according to
the General Social Survey this marks a
decline from a from 60 percent over 60
in 2008 indicating a shift in religious
beliefs the survey also reveals that 34
of Americans never attention urge the
highest figure recorded in five decades
Additionally the number of Americans
claiming no religion has increased from
27 percent in 2022 up from 19 in 2012
while religious affiliation and church
attendance continue to decline belief in
some form of higher power remains a
prevalent nearly three-quarters of
Americans believe in life after death
and only seven percent of the population
identifies as atheists despite these
Trends the United States remains
relatively religious compared to other
countries so now here's so so wild about
this
uh half of America more than half of
America believed the Russia collusion
was a real deal so they're willing to
believe
fake narrative like that for three years
and then Durham comes in and points it
out but to have a hard time believing in
God but I have to see it because I have
to see it to believe that there's a god
dude you never saw anything about Russia
but you believed in Russia delusion with
me you have to see nobody you know about
to do was a little bit of Russian stuff
going on no there was nothing going on
it was just something that you believe
in it so the second concern here is the
following you know you know who
historically governments and
establishments always feared who they've
feared they've always feared men and
women who believed in a higher power
above the government above the
establishment The Establishment doesn't
like that because the establishment
secretly their desire is to be God their
dream is to be God their dream is to be
feared their dream is they're jealous
they you know it says God is jealous you
know the establishment is way more
jealous than goddess they want all the
attention they want all the control they
want all the Limelight the difference
between a you know relationship with a
God where it's you know free will you
and I get to make some dumb choices and
we do on a daily basis and we go through
that and we pay the price for it the
establishment doesn't want to give you
the Free Will these establishment wants
you to do what they want you to do you
do they want to control you so you know
for me there's a part of this that for
some people that are listening to this
everybody falls into one of three
categories you're either part of the
oblivious Camp which is a big percentage
let's say 80 percent is the oblivious
Camp what is the oblivious Camp man I
don't have time to pay I don't really
have an influence you think my vote
really counts I don't really I just want
to have my beer and watch a football
game and you know what I don't even know
what's going on with Bud Light I go to
Coors and Heineken I don't know what's
going on do you believe this crowd okay
number two is the anti-establishment
crowd
the anti-establishment crowd
historically who is in that camp let's
give some names Andrew Jackson
anti-establishment crowd uh John F
Kennedy the Kennedy's anti-establishment
crowd Ronald Reagan anti-establishment
crowd Ross Perot anti-establishment
crowd Trump anti-establishment crowd
Bernie Sanders anti-establishment crowd
until he caved Elon Musk
anti-establishment crowd I can go on and
on give you so many different names
Ronald Reagan out of all the money that
was spent in his campaign he spent 9.6
percent of his own money to put into it
Trump was 72 percent Ross Pro was 97
percent didn't take any money from
anybody when Kennedy was running his
father said I will use 100 of my life
savings to make sure my son ends up
becoming a president he only ended up
using 50 of the entire campaign I think
was like 25 million bucks at a time
where Joseph Kennedy was worth 400
million dollars in the 60s so you look
at some of these things and you look at
Hillary Clinton you know how much money
she spent on her campaign zero of her
own money you know how much Biden spent
on the campaign nothing they don't go
and use their own money they use money
from other people they're The
Establishment they're controlled you
have to know the direction of Faith you
may say Pat what does this have to do
with God this is what it has to do with
god
um
I'm a pretty paranoid guy I'm a
skeptical Guy this is what happens when
you're Middle Eastern you're you
naturally have a hard time for The
Establishment you naturally have a hard
time with Faith Church I was an atheist
for 25 years of my life because I saw
stuff in church and I didn't like it and
I saw stuff on the government I didn't
like it I saw the gamesmanship all this
other stuff here's what I will tell you
um
the more your family and your kids don't
believe in a higher power they will
replace that with another higher power
and that higher power is you when you're
alive but when you die that higher power
could end up being the government when
you're dead
I would much rather have my kids
make the mistake of believing there's a
God and when they die they realize there
isn't then risk my kids not believing
there's a God and they make the
government being the God and then risk
being controlled and we die we're like
shoot there was a God the risk is better
having faith in your life because you
don't fear powerful men men of Faith
Don't Fear The Establishment men of
Faith don't fear dying because they
believe there's afterlife men of Faith
speak in a completely different way than
men of the establishment if there's ever
been a time ever I told you last night
what did I tell you last night at 10
o'clock at night what'd I say to you
last night I said a lot but the church
part what I say to you go to Temple go
to Temple I'm not even a Jew I said go
to the go to the temple your Mormon
you're not going to church go to your
church you're Catholic you're not going
to go you're Christian you're not going
to go you're Muslim I don't care what it
is I will much rather have a person
believe in a faith as is not a fake
debate we need more people believing in
God this great nation of America the
miracle that it ended up becoming where
so many of us have won and got the
rewards of these men and women who
sacrifice that came before us these men
and women
casted a vision that the only thing that
gave him the credit that this is
possible that it can actually happen was
God and then we wake up a 270 year old
company called the United States of
America by the way for a longest time it
was a corporation America was founded as
a federal Corporation as well United
States of America's you can look this up
this this idea
with these men and women that became
what it is today
and other countries that have been
around a lot longer than we have then we
beat those guys yeah I don't think that
happens without God so uh uh if if you
believed in Russia collusion for three
years you can definitely start believing
in God you don't have to have all the
facts to want to believe in God your
life's going to be a lot better you're
going to become a better parent better
leader better spouse better friend
better in every possible way anyways Tom
thoughts on this story here with Wall
Street Journal no and by the way this is
not a this is not a this is a hill story
we're talking about here right this is a
hill story so what are your thoughts on
this story well I think America is still
a place of faith when you compare all
those stats to the rest of the world
America is still a place of faith and I
think that if all of us return to our
faith tradition I think we would be
treating each other better I would think
that we would be calling on our the
people we elect for higher standards of
Integrity or hell just to have a
standard of integrity and I
I can't agree with you any more
stridently with what you just said and
how you summed it up that this is the
time to lead your family to leave your
friends to lead your community and
standards of Faith integrity and
character are found in are found in
faith in in big stocks because faith can
drive character character drives people
people that come together and form
organizations called businesses Civic
groups friendships communities
um final thoughts guys before we wrap up
here rob it was great having you on the
podcast here today gang we're going to
put the website again here stopwoke.com
stopwalk.com go to it uh we'll put the
link in description chat uh uh comment
section for you to go to it again stop
woke.com you can also follow Rob all his
uh social media platform uh links will
be below you can find them at Rob Smith
is it online Rob Smith online is it the
same as well on Instagram it's the same
everywhere same everywhere beautiful Rob
Smith online uh oh I'm on a trip right
now I gotta go to New York but you got
what you got a podcast here this week
I've got a podcast tomorrow and then
next Friday is the live event with fresh
that's right next Friday is a live event
with fresh and fifth here I think June
2nd from June 2nd get your tickets
Thursday night or Friday night Friday
night uh ladies party the craziness the
arguments fights all that if you like
that kind of stuff you don't want to
miss this go to 59.90 live.com and uh
Monday is Memorial Day Dave will be
enjoying a little bit of a picnic and so
I believe it'll be a Tuesday afternoon
that the biz documents like like
literally an old school no I think I
think it just took me visually to a
place sitting in the grass with a picnic
and you're making sandwiches stuff like
that and ants Tom I've got one wish for
you on Memorial Day and it's exactly
what Pat said I want you to this weekend
I want you to be with your family and I
want you to get your freak on that's
right yeah yeah that's right Rob what's
our next podcast I don't even know what
our next spot gets we'll be back next
Tuesday we'll be back next Tuesday
fantastic have a great weekend Everybody
Take Care bye-bye